what's going on everybody welcome to
another tkinter tutorial video in this
video what we're doing is talking about
how we can start incorporating live
pricing data into our application so
there are tons of ways that we could do
this we could do this with pure Python
code grab what is JSON but just treat it
like a txt split it up and all this but
managing the data sets is it's going to
be a little bit bigger of a deal
especially once we start applying some
information to it so in let's say that
the tick data for example that we're
going to pull that's going to be live
data it's going to show every single buy
and sell and so to do that properly we
want to be able to for one differentiate
between buy and sell but then as time
goes on we're going to want it might be
a lot of data that we're pulling so we
might mean what we might say pull three
days worth of data but then we want to
have like say the open high low close
candlesticks be 30 minute data instead
of the say five minute data that we pull
stuff like that
so we're going to down the road want to
really modify the data set a lot or a
little but we want to have the ability
to so the easiest way to do that is with
a combination of quite a few things so
the first thing I'd like us to go ahead
and do is we'll come over to let's just
go to let's go to google.com for now
I'll bring this down and let's see the
first thing that I'd like us to go ahead
and do is actually in fact here's what
we'll do we'll come over here first and
we're going to import URL live import
JSON these two things are built into
Python you already have them and then
also we're going to import pandas as PD
and then import numpy as NP num pies for
number crunching for the most part and
then pandas is for data manipulation
both of these things are not
automatically included in Python you can
find out if you have it by opening up a
quick GUI here and then just try to do
import pandas and then wait a second
import numpy something like that and if
you can do that then you already have
the modules and you're good to go if you
don't already have the modules then you
are going to want to get them and let me
pull up all of the these two things
pandas and then finally I've got one
more location for this so if you're on
uh let's say Mac or um Linux you can't
use this website but if you're on
Windows this is the website i would
suggest you use to get um get these
things so let's say you want numpy you
just do ctrl f search for numpy click on
it and here's numpy these are all the
things so like for me I'm on a 64-bit
3.4 so this would be my tips not that
one this would be my download if you're
on 32-bit 3.40 this would be your
download um and if that hold almost the
difference oh actually I'm sorry this
wouldn't be your download this one this
is the most recent version so you have
those otherwise and then same thing with
pandas okay so we could type in pandas
and here's pandas right here download
pandas so we can use pandas if you are
on mice a Mac OS or maybe on a Linux
system first of all if you're on Linux
you just yep get or something or pip
install but otherwise none pi is on
numpy org and then we have pandas which
is pandas PI data org and then you would
go to get pandas and all that so
depending on on you know what operating
system you're on the actual downloading
and installation process might vary so
again for Windows I would just suggest
you use this website if you're not on
Windows to use you know these websites
or pip install or whatever you happen to
use to install modules so once we have
those things let's move that over here
you've got pandas and numpy you are
ready to get into this stuff so first of
all let's save and run this and talked a
little second about what we really want
so when we start up this application
what we want to do is the starting page
is going to be a little bit of a warning
page so we've got a start page and then
eventually we'll have a sort of home
page
but for now we're going to be doing most
of our work with the btc-e exchange so
we're going to build all of the backend
using that exchange as an example and
then we'll just kind of port everything
over to the other exchanges when we need
to and at that point we might have a
home page or a start page that lets you
pick between exchanges but as long as
we're always going to be launching into
the btc-e exchange we're not gonna have
a home page just yet it doesn't really
make much sense because every time we
would test it we have to click all these
buttons and so it's kind of annoying so
we're just gonna leave that for now but
we're still going to have this warning
page pop up and then we'll just have
them click agree and then they'll be
launched into btc-e whereas normally
they would launch into the home page so
the start page will just have a warning
like hey this is a beta program use at
your own discretion or risk or whatever
so that's what we want to do and so
we're going to do make some changes
basically so first of all we'll come up
yeah this is our app but we want to go
to start page basically this page right
here and these things here so you only
need two buttons so I'm gonna delete
button 3 and then we're actually going
to call this button 1 and button 1 pack
there and um and instead of visit page 1
visit page 2 we're going to call this
one agree and this one will be disagree
if they disagree we don't need lando we
don't need anything really besides we'll
just put quit so the hit disagree it
leaves the application otherwise if they
hit agree we want to show frame and
normally we would show frame we don't
have one yet but we which if we had a
home page we would say okay we want to
show page home page but for now we're
going to have it send it to btc-e on our
score page that doesn't exist yet but
we're right about to make it so that's
what we want to start page now the only
other major thing I'd like us to do is
we've got you know self text large font
start page sort of saying start page we
will want to say um let's let's call
this we're going to call it alpha
Bitcoin X less capitalized
Bitcoin trading application and also if
you want to do like multi-line text this
is how you can do it you can do see like
if I do this comment down here and do
blah blah blah right it's not connected
right so the way that you can get around
that is one you can use newline or
something like that but the superior
method would be three quotes as if you
were almost commenting it out but you're
not alpha Bitcoin trading application
and then we'll just kind of tap it out
whoops oh not what happened there I
thought I'd get away with tabbing it
over but I guess I can't tab it that far
um let me try let me try one more thing
before I thought we would get away with
this alpha Bitcoin trick Wow seriously
okay um if I figure out why that's not
being kind to me but anyway
I'm a Bitcoin trading application I use
at your own risk
um there is no promise promise
oh nice nuts that's going of warranty
and that's good enough for now yeah once
this goes a little longer we'll put in a
proper warning there so so now we have
that and now what we want to go ahead
and do is we've got the label let's go
ahead and see what this looks like oh
well this isn't going to work yet so
we've got page 1 page 2 we'll mind
leaving one of these just to just for
reference later on but we'll delete page
2 and instead of page 3 we're going to
call this btc-e page like that and
that's our graph page so that stays the
same uh so let's go ahead oh wait we
need to go up here so anytime you add
pages what you always have to come into
the main class here and we come down and
see we've got start page page 1 2 & 3 we
still have page 1 I'm just going to
leave that for reference we're not
actually going to use that page so we've
got start page and then we have a
be TCB underscore page like that and
those are our pages so now the other
thing I want to do oh so if they agree
they go to btc-e page back to home
should go to start page and we no longer
need a page too so we'll delete that now
let's go ahead and save and run that see
if we messed up anything so all right
indentations not the best um yeah and
it's because I added all these tabs I'm
pretty sure use it your yes there's no
problem man I had this working on my
other my actual version anyway let's
click that for a quick okay so back to
home back to this page um I guess we
could use the new lines this isn't very
long I just don't not quite confident as
to why there's what well here's a let's
try to do this on my version I do
something more like this so let's try
this version
save and run that um yeah that looks a
little better so so that's good enough
for now and we hit agree and we go to
the graph so good enough so back to home
good that's aligned well enough so X out
of this and now we want to talk about is
actually getting this data into our our
chart so we want to have the connection
to the actual btc-e servers so if you go
to bt sash deep btc-e - uh actually I
had one of my usernames in there give
her that um moving on
BTC comm um and come down to the bottom
here let's just do that and go all the
way down you get trade API there's also
public API really what we're going to be
using is the public API for now and then
we'll get into trade API but for now you
just would use public API to actually
acquire the pricing data so these are
where you would get you know pricing
basically like this stuff or this I'll
show you exactly what we're going to be
doing but here's an also here's like a
ticker so you could click on that and
this would be the current prices but
we're actually going to go for is the
trade assert while my information still
stays in there thank you google um
anyway this account has like no money on
it so
there that's actually this will be the
account that we use uh for this tutorial
so anyways um so this is uh basically
the the API and all that and so I think
what we'll do is I'll cut off this video
here and then we'll talk about in the
next video how we can connect through
the API pull that data and because it's
live data right so we can keep querying
their API so they also have a socket API
as well not really going to get into
that yet it would it'll be really cool
to incorporate that eventually into this
this um this client just because the
socket API is really cool but for now
we're just going to use the typical you
know static API where we just keep
making requests so so that's what you
guys have to look forward to in the next
video so if you guys have any questions
or comments up to this point really
we're just kind of orienting the code to
support the changes that are coming but
if you do have any questions or comments
at this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions until next time